ah
[Música]
a
quedan ya algo lejos esos años de
2016-2017 los que los periodistas serán
judicialmente perseguidos en turquía de
forma casi diaria y constante de esos
años había en las cárceles turcas 250
periodistas y ahora 2020 quedan algo más
de 100 los casos judiciales en cuanto a
perdices han bajado el ritmo pero siguen
estando allí y uno de los últimos fue un
grupo de periodistas que fue juzgado por
haber publicado que la mujer del
presidente turco recep tayyp erdogán se
compró con dinero público un bolso
hermes valorado en 50 mil dólares pero
este no es el único caso hace un par de
semanas un grupo de periodistas de una
agencia pro-kurda fue detenida en el
sureste de turquía por haber publicado
con un grupo de militares lanzó desde un
helicóptero a un ciudadano turco por el
simple hecho de ser kurdo
[Música]
en 41 años de revolución islámica hay
una larga cadena de crímenes contra
periodistas y muchos de ellos han
quedado en la impunidad como aquellos
que sucedieron en 1988 cuando una gran
cantidad de periodistas columnistas
intelectuales que trabajaban en los
medios reformistas fueron asesinados y
si bien como ha sucedido en otros casos
algunos de los que fueron señalados como
responsables terminaron en prisión nunca
sus condenas fueron lo suficientemente
altas pero también hay muchas de las
personas que estuvieron involucradas que
siguen en libertad como ha sucedido en
otros casos muchos de estos periodistas
también en estos años han muerto en
prisión por causas relacionadas con la
dureza de sus interrogatorios pero esto
no es la única razón para ser difícil el
oficio del periodismo en irán donde
muchas personas van encarceladas por su
trabajo o simplemente la dureza del
oficio del periodismo donde es muy
precario los salarios bajos y donde
cualquier momento se puede ser despedido
[Música]
reporteros sin fronteras asegura que en
marruecos persiste la presión judicial
sobre la prensa e instala o no a
condenar la instrumentalización de
delitos sexuales contra los periodistas
y es que son sonados los casos de
periodistas críticos que han acabado en
la cárcel los sancionados por este tipo
de delitos que aseguran no haber
cometido el caso más reciente es el de a
omar radi que se encuentra en la cárcel
acusado de violación y de un delito
contra la seguridad del estado antes de
entrar en prisión el periodista denunció
de la mano de amnistía internacional que
el estado espiaba su teléfono acusación
que el gobierno desmintió en todo
momento también se hizo famoso el caso
de haidar raisuni periodista del diario
ajá para el jaume que fue acusada de
libertinaje y de aborto ilegal en su
caso acabo indultada por el rey pero
algunos de sus compañeros como es el
caso de suleimán 'la razón' y el propio
director de aguará liamos tu fe como
vaselina siguen en la cárcel acusados de
agresión sexual y de trata de personas
respectivamente y en el índice mundial
de libertad de prensa 2020 establecido
por reporteros sin fronteras marruecos
ocupa el puesto 133 de 180 la región al
magreb oriente medio sería la más
peligrosa para ejercer el periodismo
[Música]